hi everyone welcome to our homeroom
livestream South Khan here from Khan
Academy for those of you who are
wondering what this is this is just
something we started up several months
ago especially when we all have to
become socially distance as a way of
having interesting topics with
interesting guests and also taking your
questions and I'm really excited about
our guest today Jacquelyn fuller from
Google org but before that I would like
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up when they
realized that Khan Academy was already
running at a deficit preak ovid and our
costs only went up whether it's server
costs or we're trying accelerate
programs or add new content in response
to school closures so special thanks to
google.org Bank of America AT&T fastly
and Novartis I will say to all of you
listening out there as much as helped
this has been from the support of these
these great organizations we are still
running at a deficit and as we know the
school closure issue isn't going away so
we're trying to do what we can but if
you're not position to do so please
think about going to Khan Academy that
org slash donate we only exist because
of philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself so any any level of
donation makes a big deal so please
think about doing that so with that I'm
excited about introducing our guest a
Jacqueline fuller president of
google.org Jacqueline great to have you
here great to be here to chat with you
Sal and and maybe a good place to start
obviously everyone knows Google some
folks know Google org
what is Google org what why does it
exist what does the dot org mean so
google.org is Google's philanthropy and
essentially or a part of the company
were a team embedded fully within Google
and the idea is to think about how can
we use the unique strengths of Google to
make the world better and specifically
how can we address issues like education
inclusion more recently taking on issues
like the Kovac crisis but doing so in a
way that brings together the best of
Google all of our assets so we're funded
through a 1% commitment
of our company's net profits each year
so it's funding north of 200 million
dollars but we also think about Google
strings in technology and our Googlers
are you know amazingly passionate
employees who also want to step in and
so we often combine teams of Googlers
who go and work alongside nonprofits
along with funding along with our reach
and our voice and advocacy and and just
to be clear I mean this is a little bit
of a disclosure but also I want to give
you and Google credit for all of those
who enjoy Khan Academy a lot of people
don't realize Khan Academy you know and
those that first back in 2010 actually
was 2009 we started conversation started
when it was just me actually in the same
walk-in closet that I'm I'm in right now
you know the folks at Google y'all were
down the road about three miles down the
road talking about ways to educate the
world there was this ten to the
hundredth project and a Khan Academy was
one of those projects and y'all gave a
significant donation at the time een
it's it's significant today do it was a
two million dollar donation that
essentially allowed Khan Academy to
exist and so I don't want to you know
embarrass you too much with too much
praise but we would not we would not
exist from that and then since then
Google org has been a sponsor or a
supporter of multiple projects at Khan
Academy but but Jacqueline may be you
know just and encourage everyone
watching to ask any questions you have
for a Jacqueline or myself on youtube or
on Facebook and I'll surface them but
Jacqueline maybe to make it more
tangible give examples of the types of
stuff I gave one you know my favorite
example supported but what other types
of things
do y'all do either in kind of the you
know traditional philanthropic support
or in that you know Google has special
skills type of support well one that's
very topical right now that comes to
mind is we're investing in racial
justice organizations and particularly
we've had a historic commitment to
helping to fight mass incarceration and
to look at racial justice reform so
about five years ago Justin Steele on my
team led an initiative where we asked
what can google do unique
to help with this issue of deep systemic
bias and so we invested resources north
of 32 million dollars in fabulous
partners like Bryan Stevenson zorg equal
justice initiative organizations such as
a Center for policing equity run by dr.
Phil Goff and so we invested in
organizations who are bringing together
data in science and trying to figure out
how can we solve some of these issues
that are deeply rooted in systemic bias
but we're having more data and evidence
and where technology can really come to
the forefront so we had a store
commitment there and more recently
because of the movement that's been
happening across the u.s. we really
wanted to make sure that these frontline
orgs orbs that are led by people of
color and really looking at what are the
solutions that are in hands so we
reinvested in them and sent resources
and additional twelve million dollars
but also Googlers I mean we have a
passionate Googlers who have unique
skill sets that they can bring to the
table so for example working with the
Vera Institute a team of Google
engineers and product managers and you
axe folks and even marketing folks came
alongside the Vera Institute and helped
bring together for the first time ever
data around jails around the countries
you know we talk a lot about federal
prisons but most folks are in jails and
there's not really one Authority
datasource that helps us look at who's
being incarcerated what are the
demographic characteristics you know how
many are in for example just because
they can't pay bonds on jail bonds so
that's the kind of work that we do where
we empower these frontline organizations
to do what they're doing and help build
them through not only their the funding
and the resources but through Googlers
I'm just curious and it sounds like
y'all are y'all have been doing this for
a little while and you're accelerating
some of this around social justice
racial justice any any kind of
surprising insights out of that I am
about the data I you know how many
people are there for I'm just making up
stuff nonviolent offenses or for not
being able to pay bond or things like
that yeah I mean it's fascinating and
and viewers can go to the Center for
policing equity or the Vera Institute
Vera just published the data that we
helped them put together with this
product but for example you know you see
that the numbers incarcerated were
pretty steady through about 1980 and
then it just hits an s-curve that looks
you know a lot like Kovan just starts to
accelerate and you see just how the
percentage that are incarcerated and
percentages by race so for example
looking at how right now because of
kovat for example politicians leaders
are having to think about is this a time
where we actually release some offenders
folks who are in prisons and jails early
in part because of kovat and having the
data to do so in an informed way to say
hey these are nonviolent offenders these
are folks who are a very low risk to
society so that that is an example of
two streams of very current research and
needs for data coming together kovat and
mass incarceration
yeah and related that have a question
here from YouTube Suzanna Garcia
Dominguez who's one of our regular great
question askers SS hi Jacqueline
what are some of your innovative
projects dealing with kovat 19 well you
know it's interesting with kovat so my
background is I used to work at the
Gates Foundation so I come from the
field of global health originally and
it's just amazing how little we actually
know how much data we actually have on
who's being infected how they're being
infected and this is particularly true
in the case of Co fit for
underrepresented groups we know that
kovat is impacting for example the black
community and the Latino community at
much higher rates than say the white
community we know that they are black
and brown
are more likely to be infected they're
more likely to be hospitalized
unfortunately more likely to die as well
but the data there to understand exactly
where the hotspots and you know what
interventions are working is not there
so we just teamed up with the Morehouse
School of Medicine who has been doing
some excellent work to gather more data
to help inform particularly how kovat is
impacting members of minority
communities so we gave them a million
dollar grant but we also sent again a
team of Googlers to work with them on
the data and one thing that happened
with that project now that was a very
recent project in about the last month
or so and we're - particularly at the
from the Google expertise side helping
with the use of AI artificial
intelligence of machine learning to make
sure that we're taking that data and
helping the teams there turn that into
actionable information but the
Department of Health and Human Services
came alongside us in that project very
quickly afterwards and invested an
additional 40 million and I think that
that's a good example of what
philanthropy can do because at the end
of the day the real engines of change
the real engines of scale are the market
and government and but I think
philanthropy can play a role where we're
more catalytic where we can help really
at the beginning kind of like we did
with you sell to help give that seed
funding at the beginning to say this is
a brilliant idea
we love Khan Academy we believe in it
let's help invest in it in the beginning
let's help to send technology teams as
well so we're trying to do that with
COBIT as well yeah it was super there's
a bunch of questions coming in but
actually it would be interesting you
know I think one of the fun things about
this livestream is we have a lot of
young people watching they're trying to
figure out their own lives that you know
I remember being young I guess I'm not
anymore and looking at you know people
that seem successful and said how did
they get there so so maybe it'd be fun
to take a little step back and on but
then I do want to ask where you hope you
will and google.org goes but just your
own personal you know how did you get
into this career like is this a career
like you know running a foundation or
core
foundation or philanthropy I mean it is
a career but like you know there's no
major in college around it so it tell us
a little bit about what you thought you
were gonna do growing up and and and how
that evolved to where you are now yes I
did not grow up as a little girl
thinking to myself someday I want to run
corporate philanthropy ah so this was a
bit of a zig zag trail to get to where I
am and so I actually started when I was
young having a very strong commitment to
social justice and not really
understanding or knowing how I could
best make an impact but just having that
is kind of my Northern Star I knew I
really wanted to invest myself and my
time and my effort my skills into an
area where I was moving the needle and
social justice so I actually started
right out of college I went and to work
in the government because at the time
you know if you wanted to change things
at scale you joined the government so I
worked actually at the Department of
Health and Human Services and in
Washington DC and I was I think the most
junior person you could possibly hire at
the time but I worked on issues of
health disparities actually with
minority communities and under dr. Lewis
elleven who was the head of HHS at the
time and was actually confident Lee the
founder of the Morehouse full of
Medicine
so coming full circle so I worked in
government for a couple of years and
then I thought I really would like to
invest in myself deepen my understanding
my knowledge my technical skills as well
so I went and got a master's in public
policy from the Kennedy School of
Government and you know while I was
there actually got pregnant and my
husband and I had a nice surprise when I
was in graduate school so we had our
first daughter
hosannah so I took some time where I
really focused on being a mom to two
young kids and then when I went back
just to work on after a few years there
was this new startup we were living in
Seattle at the time called the Gates
Foundation and Bill Gates said I read an
article where Bill Gates said I am going
to give the majority of my money away
and I'm gonna give it to help the
poorest of the poor and I just thought
hire me I will help you so threw myself
at the gates of the Gates Foundation and
eventually got a job there I was there
for about eight years and then I heard
about another crazy startup called
google.org and I thought okay I have you
know I've worked in government and
private philanthropy I've never actually
worked in a company I'd like to see what
companies can do and this sounds like a
very interesting startup so I came down
to join google.org about 12 years ago
yeah and your your path is very
connected to us because you know back in
2010 the two organizations that frankly
allowed Khan Academy to become a real
organization we're at Google and the
Gates Foundation with that first-rounder
and then they have obviously since then
been great supporters it's all connected
what do you think has kind of
contributed to your success here like
what do you think has made you good at
what you do missing down really boring
when I say this but number one is hard
work
I think I I I had to outwork a lot of
people to get to where I am and be
smarter and be better and be more
resilient and inhabit and I think that's
kind of been a new boutique area of
study Angela I think it's Duckworth and
others have really overdone and yeah oh
she's fabulous and you have really done
the research studies on grit and how
important of a characteristic that that
is but you know I mentioned for example
when I was at the Kennedy School I had
my daughter hose on Oh in the middle of
my second year and Kennedy school said
we recommend you leave and I said no I
think I'm gonna graduate and they gave
me no parental leave there was no such
thing at the time it didn't actually
exist and so I had her on a Thursday and
I went back to school on Monday and I
got well you know I got no break I had
to finish every single thesis and
and experience and whatnot um so there
have been times in my career where I
think really digging deep having having
that grit and perseverance and hard work
is super important I would say the other
thing sal is i just have always run
towards my energy I've always run
towards what really likes me off and I
think you know we hear a lot about
follow your passion but at some level I
think it's actually true find that
source of energy that really is gonna
get you up in the morning and help you
read that research article and
surrendered your energy but also ask
yourself and how am I gonna get paid to
do this and you know what where can I
uniquely plug in where can I make the
most difference follow my energy but
realistically you know be able to build
a career and a well-being that's gonna
be sustainable so I never really had a
path like oh I definitely want to work
in flames beer I definitely want to do
this or that but I've used more those
those guidelines and characteristics and
it definitely is I mean there's so just
even in the the story you told us you
know this the fact that you read about
the Gates Foundation starting I think a
lot of the world probably read about it
but there's something and you said I
want them to hire me that I think
mindset and they said no they said no so
many times so the the article came out
and the Gates Foundation was just
starting and it was very much in stealth
mode and so they said the reporter was
led into their office which was in a
above a pizza shop in Redmond Washington
and so I drove over to Redmond
Washington and I looked at all the pizza
shops and I look for one with an office
above it and I basically figured out
where they were and then I go to there
every day and I would shove my resume
and my cover letter into their mailbox
and you know make a case for why they
needed to hire me and why I would you
know so be so great on their team and
then they would email me back a very
polite rejection and
like three times and this is a true
story Sal this is a true story and then
after the third time literally I got
this email from Jack Barris who said I
will meet you for 15 minutes at
Starbucks in Redmond if you promise to
never bother us again
and he ended up hiring me you stalked
the Gates Foundation I I showed some
great verses I mean case I made the case
of why I brought them value I've learned
that you don't need to make don't make
the case young people people who are
trying to get a job do not make the case
of why such and such is your dream job
don't don't convince Sal working at the
Khan Academy is your dream job convince
Sal that you are gonna be a value to him
that you are going to make his life
easier that you are bringing a skill set
that he desperately needs because that's
one thing I've learned as an employer
and sitting on the other side of the
table
no and that's right as much as you know
I would like to believe that yes I you
are definitely drawn to people who can
make your life easier
and who can and who can help fulfill a
broader mission or vision that you are
you're part of are invested in well I am
curious that I mean this is a much more
interesting story than I expected when
we kind of started double-clicking on it
what was what was that meeting like I
mean you know if this person who's kind
of trying to get rid of you you've been
you know sending them a resume he's not
taking no for an answer
like I'm assuming he didn't have the
posture of like I'm really excited about
this conversation no but he was a
gracious man that's why I named him and
he and look I also had to be flexible on
my end right so I had just you know I
had a Harvard degree I had published
research I was funded by the Ford
Foundation to do some of my own research
and when I was pitching myself I was
pitching myself more as hey I can help
with econometrics I can do em any
measurement and evaluation they're all
these various I'm you know public policy
and he was like yeah I don't I don't
think we're ready actually for advocacy
or Public Policy and I don't actually
even know what econometrics are but
thank you um but you know he started to
think and he was like you're a very good
writer and we actually need someone to
write our brochure and so if I was
literally hired in order to write their
brochure so a couple lessons here
especially for women and girls who might
be listening one thing is I think
sometimes we have to get our foot in the
door and being willing to be a little
bit flexible and the other thing is when
he said we need someone to write our
first brochure and to design it and work
with vendors and get it published and he
said is that something you can do and I
started to do the typical girl thing
like oh I've never well I've never done
that before but you know I'd be happy to
try and something came up that some
spirit came up out of me and I was like
absolutely I can do that and so I was
hired on contract to do their first
brochure and it went okay and then he
they were like you know we actually need
someone now to create our first website
is that something you can do and again
you know Sal I observe go experience
with websites I barely understood the
internet and could function on email at
the time but I said absolutely
I can absolutely build a website and so
I think sometimes just being brave
taking that step believing in yourself
and then eventually I got hired and when
I left I was the deputy director of the
global health program eight years later
and I used to bring Bill and Melinda
Gates to Africa and India and Pakistan
and all over the world - for weeks at a
time to do their learning and their
education and advocacy trips so really
appreciate that Gates was willing to
take a bet on me and early in my career
no there's a lot because lesson is you
had some real skills that you had built
over time and so you know the real
message for for those young people I am
I feel old now whenever I say that but
for those young young people listening
is build up your skills as well as
possible and in that you know I think
the writing skill the critical think
skill and just the can do witness skill
yeah
then with a with a little sprinkle of
resilience and self-confidence can go a
long way is what I'm hearing
yeah and you know especially I get asked
a lot from people who really want to
have a career in social impact and I'm I
bet you get this a lot to sell or people
are saying they're coming fresh out of
college maybe a few years out and
they're saying I want to make a
difference I really want to invest my my
whole self my career in social justice
or making an impact changing the world
changing climate change I often tell
them the most important thing you can do
right now is to build and develop a
tangible hard skill and that hard skill
can be writing it can be critical
writing it can be coding it can be
finance and auditing it can be PR be an
excellent product manager but really the
nonprofit sector the government
philanthropy the do-gooder sector needs
people with hard skills and experience
so invest in yourself develop those
skills and and do that first and bring
and bring those into your lifetime
career and there's a question here from
YouTube from Jasper not even a rapper
says Jacqueline what would you say to
help market yourself in a climate where
your degree might not apply or be useful
skill and this is a very relevant
question right now obviously we're at
record levels of unemployment there's
new jobs new industries all the time
that have no degrees for them how does
someone transition or if their resume
doesn't say that they're meant for that
how do they convince folks
great question Jasper you heard my story
and the fact that I had to believe in
myself and be willing to really learn
and do different things and come into a
job where I was going to have a steep
learning curve so I think part of it is
that flexibility on our part you know as
people I think also look the world is
changing so much and degrees especially
you know what major you were and what
you know Great Scott your major I think
these kinds of things are going to
matter less and less and it's gonna be a
lot about life lifelong learning so you
know using resources like Khan Academy
for example learning taking new skills
new certifications are gonna make you
very relevant in the job market I will
say the other thing Jasper is that we
need to change the employers need to
change we need to get off of our
fixation on degrees and 4-year degrees
really and actually hire for skills and
that's gonna really help us to have a
more diverse workforce it's gonna really
help us build better products and so at
Google for example one thing that we
have done is to really try to reevaluate
our requirements for our jobs and to
really state a four-year college degree
not required or CS major not required if
you have the skills at hand needed for
this role so there's movement that's
needed on both sides of that you know
that's super valuable and I realize
these conversations they always go way
faster than I expect them to because I I
could talk for another hour just even on
this career aspect of it but I want to
make sure there's space to talk about
kind of the future of google.org and
your work there and maybe we can even
connected I mean there's this question
from YouTube from Newport metha how hard
is it to run a company I mean that goes
into a whole you know kind of your day
to day and what are your what are your
stresses or your hopes and maybe how
does that flow into what you hope
google.org is able to do over the years
to come well you know it's something
said to me once and I I didn't believe
it at the time I thought they were
making it up but it um it was a FEMA
female executive I'm forgetting who but
she said you know it's actually easier
to be CEO than it was to be like a line
director it's actually easier sometimes
as you move up the food change because
you're able to control your schedule
more control your life more focus on the
things that you're good at and hire
excellent people to cover all of the
areas that you're really not good at and
so I would say that that's true and I'm
and I see that as a word of
encouragement to people who are maybe
wondering if they have what it takes to
go to that next level to be CEO or see
Oh or to run the show at whatever level
and I think sometimes when you're
looking up at that and you think well
I'm working so hard right now and I'm so
stressed right now it must be 10x at
that level actually sometimes it's
easier because you have more control so
that's just something to consider about
you know the question about being the
boss and I've always believed also I was
told early on hire people who are
smarter and better than you are
don't be threatened by them and so I
have always tried to hire an a-team
and I my deputies are smarter better
than me in so many ways and empowering
your people so that you're not alone you
know you there's not this lonely list at
the top or feeling that you're carrying
the weight of Atlas on your shoulders
I've built a very collaborative
leadership team where I feel like we are
carrying the load together I have people
like Hannah Peter for example who is
running our education portfolio and it's
done a lot of the work that we've been
doing more recently with Khan Academy
with DonorsChoose and being able to
trust someone like her Andrew Dunkleman
and say hey you all have this I'm I'm
gonna just listen to your
recommendations here has been amazing in
terms of in increasing the impact that
google.org can have and frankly helping
me to be a better leader and what you
know with that lens and I think I need
some coaching from you because I I
definitely have things that I'm always
coping with and part of it there the
loneliness is part of it sometimes if
I'm honest yeah but but what what is
your hope you know for actually I'll
broaden it for Google org over the years
to come and even for your own direct
impact either through Google at order or
or broadly I mean so my dream is
actually that we find and fund and
support and empower a thousand Sal
Khan's right you you are actually our
success story right because our job is
to
invest provide this seed funding the
catalytic funding that is necessarily
that is necessary and I think
philanthropic capital can take risks and
you know companies like Google tech
companies can be particularly useful I
think when it comes to investing in
technology a lot of funders and
governments and private individuals
don't feel like they know or understand
enough about let's say technology or
artificial intelligence they're just not
going to invest in those organizations
so that's something I think we should
always ask ourselves either as
individuals as companies where am i
uniquely gifted how can I make a
difference that is builds on on my
unique strengths so for google.org we
are Google we are a technology company
and technology is desperately needed in
the social impact sector so that's where
we're doubling down so when an issue
comes up like education or kovat we
think about what are the platforms what
are the scaled ways that are leveraging
technology where we could really help
shift the curve so when Sal when you
came along I don't know if I've never
told you this story but part of it was
that my husband John is an elementary
school teacher and he has been a
classroom teacher for almost 30 years
and he was an early user of the Khan
Academy oh I need that I need to send
him a box of chocolates oh man a big box
and with some chocolate in there because
his wife likes it but um you know I saw
firsthand what a difference Khan Academy
made for a classroom teacher and then
later in life so my daughter
hosana who was born I said when I was in
grad school so she majored in computer
science actually in college and when she
need help with help with you know her
homework or her problem sets or really
wanted to understand something that was
happening in the classroom she went to
Khan Academy and she was so you were
tremendously helpful in her career so I
I've been personally able to see you
know firsthand how helpful Khan Academy
is that's why we invested in the begin
but then also I benefited from those
fruits later on with my daughter where I
think for terribly as a female and in
computer science it was tremendously
helpful for her to have a resource to go
to know well that's always wonderful
here and actually you never did tell me
I mean back in 2000 and it was actually
2009 when we started first having the
conversations with Google I remember you
know I was kind of overwhelmed not
knowing what to make of it I used to
walk he said like placemats slides and I
remember there was a big room of folks
that said like what would you do with
more resources a lot of us have been
using it we didn't realize you were just
one some guy in a closet operating three
miles down the road it was all it was
all interesting time it's fun to talk
about it in hindsight now but yeah it
was yeah it was it was it was
interesting well well Jacqueline I mean
we got it we've got to do this again if
you're if you're up for it but we're
unfortunately all out of time
but any you know final thoughts words
words of wisdom ideas things you want to
throw out there I mean we are in a
moment right now not only in the US but
globally we are in a moment there's
something like two billion kids who are
not able to go to the traditional
schooling that they had if there was
ever a moment for the Khan Academy to
come up and shine and be utilized it is
this moment so I don't think I mentioned
earlier but we actually just regram
titta ghin to Khan Academy he did not
ask me to say this but let me say we
just gave additional funding in the last
couple months because we recognize this
is a global moment where we need to be
investing in platforms that hit scale
that are available in local languages in
content that teachers can use teachers
are the heroes they are the frontline
essential workers this is a way that we
can all invest in them so thank you Khan
Academy thank you Sal thank you everyone
out there who is working to make the
world a better place in your own unique
way this is a moment yeah well obviously
I couldn't agree more and Jacqueline
thank you so much for obviously the work
that you've been able to do with us and
and help
helped do our mission but also well
beyond that the incredible work that you
all are doing a group at work thank you
so much for joining thanks so much Sal
appreciate it thank you so thanks
everyone for joining as always I really
you know something my perception of time
changes what we're having a good
conversation it goes by very very fast
but as you could tell them I'm not a
really really fun conversation
I will we're not going to be doing a
live stream tomorrow but we will be
having I think we're Tuesday we're going
to be coming back we have two guests
next week both very very interesting
Casey Wasserman famous I guess you could
say agent in the sports and
entertainment world so I think there
should be some really interesting
conversation there and you might not
have heard of this I dr. Anthony foutch
E to talk about obviously the situation
that we're all we're all in in together
so we look forward to seeing you next
week
you